[Música]
o homem caminhava apressadamente uma
plataforma vai pegar um trem trazia das
mãos as luvas quando ele entrou no trem
e sentou ele percebeu que uma luva tinha
sumido
ele olhou para o chão da plataforma e
descobriu que ela estava lá o que ele
fez
jogou outra luva para quem encontrasse
pesquisar o pa
essa história me emocionou muito quando
vi ela pela primeira vez porque ela me
deu uma sensação de que a gente pode sim
fazer diferente apenas observando nosso
entorno
essa história sobre a metáfora da luva
tá é uma uma brincadeira que me fez
realmente pensar muito e me deixa muito
emocionado como uma história que
aconteceu aqui em santa catarina em 2014
quando eu era a é consultor criativo do
santa catarina moda e cultura
naquele momento a gente pediu para os
times criativos trazerem para o nosso
convívio e discussão
os personagens catarinense que estavam
praticando o que eu chamo de jiu jitsu
cultural
ou seja pegando uma fraqueza e
transformou numa estratégia um dos times
trouxe pra gente um personagem muito
inspirador e que realmente mudou minha
vida para sempre
o jairo lumertz um surf de garopaba que
fazia pranchas de garrafa pet
mas estava trabalhando com a
sustentabilidade só que tinha coisa mais
bacana ainda ele usava o seu poder de
comunicação desenvolvimento para limpar
as praias com crianças e ensinar as
crianças a fazer suas pranchas e com
elas também surfar mais importante do
que apenas fazer a prancha e ensinar
fire estava plantando a semente na nova
geração não é para que eles pudessem ser
ali no futuro próximo os novos
disseminadores das práticas de
sustentabilidade
isso mudou minha vida muito foi muito
sério eu fiquei pensando porque existe
uma nova ordem acontecendo esses gestos
muito simples podem fazer a gente
realmente tornar
personagem de transformação foi que eu
entendi que existe uma nova economia né
uma nova prática de negócios que era
movida pelo afeto eu batizei isso em
2014 a economia efetiva que trabalha
exatamente assim uma nova perspectiva de
mercado que valoriza o coletivo para
criar produtos e processos disruptivos e
inovadores
usando o design como ferramenta de
transformação em tudo o sabão que o
poder do coletivo o poder do coletivo
poder do coletivo foi simples como eu
posso levar o poder coletivo pra moda já
que a gente trabalha é sempre
autocrática autoritária verticalizada
que apontar erros aponta certos né eu
fiquei lá mergulhado pensando pensando
como é que eu vou aí tal estudar pra
estudar como chama seus livros o pessoal
que aconteceu antes disso né
um pouco antes disso um pouco mais antes
disso para poder descobrir onde podia
ter uma chave que esse aí foi que as
coisas começaram a mudar
eu cheguei no punk esse movimento jovem
rebelde 70 e 80 nessa virada de década
onde os jovens britânicos se rebelaram
contra o sistema e resolveram fazer as
suas próprias verdades as suas próprias
roupas
as novas bandas rompendo com todo o
sistema e criando também os próprios
meios de comunicação os fazeres e aí eu
percebi que esse essa idéia de faça você
mesmo
neldo tinha self que a moda batizou como
uma grande transformação tinha chegado
num ponto de esgotamento fazer você
mesmo o dava mais conta de entender o
que estava acontecendo nas redes na
internet onde a gente hoje se comunica e
se revela na então se comece a observar
na na rede esses movimentos do cabelo
crespo do cabelo natural dos novos
corpos luz das novas identidades de
gênero nos guarda-roupas compartilhados
na cultura de brechó eu percebi que tudo
aquilo era potencializado por que a
gente não podia mais fazer sozinho
então pra mim o bloco do eu sozinho não
dava mais e aí fiquei pensando que tem
que sair de cena totalmente o faça você
mesmo e entra em cena o faço com os
outros e faça para os outros
isso ficou na minha cabeça né como
fervilham eu falei tem uma coisa
que tem
é a mexida essas pessoas esses grupos
estão se encontrando de forma muito é
permeável natural que essa sintonia
as pessoas estão sintonizados por um
sentido comum e eu fiquei pensando é
isso a moda não pode ser mais sobre
roupas ela tem que ser sobre muitas
outras coisas e aí procurando pensadores
de pessoas que pudessem me conectar com
essa verdade que pudesse se impute já
que na verdade estava entendendo que
está vendo a mudança e isso pode ser
contado por meio de algum outros de
outro de alguma outra explicação é
influenciada bom olhar quem está falando
sobre isso
encontrei nas palavras do sociólogo
francês michel maffesoli a ideia a ideia
da era do afeto né
na era do afeto considerada pelo chama
acesa lhe uma uma negação ou uma
evolução do que aconteceu na modernidade
onde a gente ficava falando de
individualismo de independência na pós
modernidade que é onde a gente vive
agora não era o feto
a gente fala de sentimento e sobretudo
de interdependência
mergulhei no na era da festa da fé do
lixo e também pensando por seu
sentimento é a sintonia mas temos agora
uma nova busca pela espiritualidade uma
busca um incessante sobre o
autoconhecimento e além de tudo e pra
mim o mais importante é buscar essa
vibração artística que move esses novos
processos
essa frase do bicho uma vez ele falou
muito bem sobre o que era do feto e que
transforma a gente dentro da economia
efetiva eu vivi sinto pelo outro e
graças a outro sai de cena então essa
idéia do egoísmo e do meu pessoal do
acúmulo de bens nem eu tenho teu t e
entra em cena a horizontalidade a
vocação pelo sucesso do grupo onde todo
mundo ganha igual onde a transparência
nas relações e o total engajamento como
moeda de troca mas afinal pensando sobre
economia criativa quem são as pessoas
que estão interessadas nessa tal da
economia efetiva e por isso deve ter
alguém interessado deve se a decisão
tivesse que essas pessoas que estão
preocupadas com o consumo consciente
consumo consciente e vai parar de
comprar de consumir não é se preocupar
com quem está praticando a agenda
positiva do bem que procura qualidade de
propósito e que sobretudo usa como
ferramenta de trabalho a lógica
essa pessoas marcas do planeta são bem
não negociáveis na era do feto
nessa que nós chamamos de a moda para o
novo mundo
mas afinal que mundo é esse
eu gosto de falar que o mundo tá bom
boca né é caucasus completo distopia
enfim essa confusão de opiniões
contrárias falta de diálogo é o mundo
volátil incerto complexo e ambíguo onde
cada dia a gente tem que trabalhar com
transformações rápidas respostas muito
rápidas para problemas complexos e
sobretudo entender que a gente sim
precisa aprender com os nossos próprios
erros
um exemplo muito bacana que acontece no
brasil que é o pop blues da flávia
durante uma jornalista e dj que se
entender completamente fora do mercado
de moda né como consumidor porque
existiam marcas que pensavam sobre a sua
realidade de corpo plus foi o que ela
fez
aplicou de ajuste estrutural né nesse
mercado que não absorvi ela como uma
pessoa que estava apta e prestes a
comprar ou seja pegou fraqueza
transformou na estratégia
hoje o mercado só cresce de marcas já
passa de 760 aumento do número de
seguidores aumenta os lucros né
mais não podemos fazer como flávia que
há a fazer uma coleção de moda mas a
minha marca na flávia fez isso porque
ela estava dentro do processo a pessoa
do centro da confusão a pessoa do centro
do mundo juca pessoa no centro do caos
só ela pode ter autoridade para falar
sobre esse assunto né então assim quando
você pensar em fazer sem fazer sobre
fazer uma marca plus size uma linha para
os sites você precisa ter na sua marca
no seu processo criativo uma pessoa
possais tá isso que a gente chama de
protagonismo né
é uma qualidade da festa da economia
efetiva que trabalha de uma forma
totalmente na horizontal
nesse discurso todo né de achaque
não podemos colocar pessoas que não
representam aquele lugar de favorito do
processo criativo a gente ter exatamente
isso aí que não podemos descolar mais
discurso
de prática ok e quem são os
protagonistas catarinas que estão
trabalhando sobre essa ética sob essa
ótica
eu fiquei pensando que pra facilitar
esse esse comprei essa compreensão dessa
tal economia afetiva que virou a minha
bandeira de trabalho seria fácil dividir
em três narrativas bem claras para vocês
entenderem como elas podem impactar
gente então tem um movimento do novo
velho um movimento de efeito boomerang e
da conversa cultural um novo velho
a gente trabalha com a idéia de novos
valores e significados para produtos
relações de produção não é só o site não
é só trazer ter sido parado estoque não
é só buscar a sobra de de malha de jeans
enfim que tá ali jogado ou trabalhar com
o resíduo texto é colocar as pessoas que
vão trabalhar com você na idéia do
coletivo no centro do processo tem um
exemplo muito bacana que acontece aqui
em santa catarina que é da marca das
catarinas da design é da pesada que
cansada de ver tanto rabe a rebarba de
malha da indústria têxtil catarinense
jogada no lixo começou a juntar esse
material se associou com um grupo de
costureiras e artesãs de joinville
construiu esse valor o texto
estou desenvolvendo essa idéia da moda
para além das roupas colares vasos
almofadas mobiliário pensando sempre que
também não era efetiva da economia
efetiva a casa um corpo a ser investido
dentro da ótica da sustentabilidade
eu gosto muito de falar da esta porque
ela também foi apresentada em 2014
na época do jiu jitsu cultural e assim
como ela também conhecia flávio vanelli
que é uma designer de jaraguá do sul que
tem um trabalho muito bacana e
representa a nossa segunda narrativa o
efeito bumerangue onde a gente vai ter
que entender a consistência do negócio
social e compartilhamento de ganhos
conhecimento projeto delas amarrado roy
e ela construiu junto com a associação
de catadores de lixo jaraguá do sul essa
separação de sacolas de plástico do lixo
que submetidas à alta temperatura
viravam é com a matéria muito bacana o
trabalho de colorido peça como flávio
segue inclusive separar por cores a para
fazer uma matéria só amarelo é o
material mais azul e esse material no
começo do começo do começo ela começou a
aplicar em luminárias em bancos e hoje
ela consegue um avanço maravilhoso
trabalho criando uma linha de óculos
quando a gente para não pensar sobre a
flávia vanelli o que é interessante é
distinto que ganha mais nesse processo a
flávia os catadores
vale ressaltar que na economia efetiva
todo mundo ganha igual nem os nossos
corpos são permeáveis a gente recebe
informação do outro assimila e
transformam alguma forma uma informação
nova a falha faz isso os catadores
ganham também todo mundo sai feliz
nós vamos falar na ativa eu chamo de
conversa cultural que basicamente o que
a gente está fazendo aqui do tradex
blumenau salon que é criar ambientes
provocativos para encontrar soluções
transformadoras
o case que eu trago é o trabalho efetivo
que eu tive a honra de realizar com a
fundação hair em 2016 fundação german ré
de blumenau onde a gente tinha como
principal desafio tentar entender
diminuir a lacuna entre o estudo formal
do design de moda nas escolas ea
realidade do mercado
esse gap muito grande usando como
ferramenta de trabalho a tal da
logística reversa que eu falei
anteriormente onde a gente podia aplicar
o site do im
o reaproveitamento de material né
reaproveitamento de lixo texto destarte
enfim a gente fez o que a juntar a esse
projeto sair do papel e ganhar corpo com
a vida ganha rua joel brasil
a gente fez uma reunião de design os
orientadores como marcelo rosenbaum
o alexandre reche convite ea patrícia
centurion
todos eles auxiliados pelo grupo
produtivo cardume de mães que trabalha
há dez anos com a idéia de
reaproveitamento de matéria prima
descartada para a construção de
acessórios
juntos os nos conectamos com um grupo de
11 pessoas
designers artistas plásticos arquitetos
todos seus estudantes de modo todos
selecionados pela internet por leitura
de portfólio pessoas que estava
interessado em usar a economia efetiva
como a parte do seu novo processo de
transformação ea gente fez o que se
juntou com essa galera dois meses dentro
de um galpão fazendo
são criativos do processo de vida de
cada um que eles podiam trazer de
vocação para essa transformação de
produtos e processos
contando uma linda história protótipo
pando uma nova linha de peças a partir
do descarte trecho da companhia hering e
esse descarte texto eles escolheram como
o jeans matéria prima para a função do
projeto e desenvolveram um dos festivais
uma linha de de vasos uma toalha de mesa
com um banco e até mesmo a luminária em
2017 a gente resolver o drama afetiva
tinha que deixar de ser apenas um
projeto e passar a viajar a gente
invadiu a igrejinha de o tim festival
meca
levamos a nossa fala levam alguns das
espécies ficamos duas horas conversando
com as pessoas interessa diz nessa pauta
depois a gente foi para são paulo e
depois nahmad que é a principal feira de
é design e design colecionava do brasil
entendemos ali dentro do prédio da
bienal entendemos ali que o que a gente
estava fazendo era o movimento de
pessoas que conectam pessoas e usam a
moda com uma plataforma de transformação
social cultural e ambiental
nos conectamos com alexandre reche
convite com lino villaventura com
ronaldo fraga com gustavo silvestre
enfim lá de aranha
ela estava morto uma série de designs
que estavam praticando a economia
efetiva depois a gente se conectou com
esses novos conectores sobre o rio é
fazer essa fala e mostrar as nossas
peças no youtube space em tudo o mais
legal não foi viajar não foi entender
que a gente virou um projeto de um
movimento foi perceber que no começo de
tudo as pessoas que sentiam ilhas mas
ela se sentir parte de um grande pé logo
tudo vibrava em cima da palavra empatia
eu em 30 anos de trabalho na indústria
de volta aplicou o mesmo giro cultural
todo dia pra poder manter viva as
reflexões fazendo como ocupando todos os
espaços físicos e utópicos com as minhas
próprias incertezas
por fim eu queria convidar vocês a fazer
exatamente como o cara da metáfora da
luva usar nossas próprias
mãos para fazer com os outros e para os
outros obrigado
[Aplausos]